uh well whether a deal is agreed or not
there are
just 18 days until the rules governing
trade between the uk and the eu change
so it's not an easy time for businesses
that rely on trade with europe to plan
uh let's talk about that challenge we're
joined now by the president of the
british
chambers of commerce banners ruby
mcgregor smith barnett lovely to see you
this morning
um well let's dive straight on in shall
we how likely is it do you think that
we're going to get a deal
i your guess is as good as mine i'm
hoping that business needs a deal and we
need it
as soon as possible because we need to
understand how we're going to trade and
what the rules are
well just on that i mean how many of
your members would you say are actually
ready good to go come january the first
come
well a deal or not a deal i think it's
very difficult to be ready because there
are a number of areas where we don't
have any detail at all such as
we don't understand anything around
quote tariffs or quotas
we don't understand anything in detail
about rules of origin
we don't have tariff codes we don't know
the detail of the northern ireland
protocol and if we do get a deal we
still don't know
what the uk structural fund is going to
look like it's going to support the
more you know the more challenged areas
of the uk
and all of this on top of a pandemic as
well and the detail
and we found with a pandemic that what
mattered was the detail
of whatever has been agreed on
government support and this is exactly
going to be the same it's now the 13th
of december
so for those of us that don't have your
glittering cv when it comes to
industry and business explain that the
practical consequences
of not having the the kind of the
granular detail required
to operate you know operate your
business post 2020.
so we're not going to know what tariffs
could be imposed on any good
leaving the country or any good coming
into the country which means we won't
know the price
and although many have been agreed the
detail is going to be
in either a deal or a no deal scenario
it's still really lacking
and what we and look at the end of the
day the gov what i've urged the
government to do with the british
chambers of commerce we've urged them
along to give us clarity
on what is being agreed and there's
still a significant number of issues
that aren't agreed
on detail given that do you believe the
conservatives still
to be the party of business
i really want them to be the party of
business all
political parties should support
business but this
year what we've seen in the pandemic is
huge amounts of support given but we
still have a significant number of
industries shut down
that aren't open and on top of this we
don't know how we're going to be trading
from the 1st of january
so i just want to urge everybody to get
on
and get us the deal that we need so we
can actually start to grow as businesses
without that deal absent a deal we are
looking at
businesses going under aren't we we are
looking at people being made redundant
in their thousands
there there could be some significant
job losses and
that on top of lack of government
support after march
as we come out of pandemic and i would
urge the government to look at the
support all businesses need as we come
out of this and
also give us more time to prepare as we
leave the european union
where has been the failure in all of
this and failure there clearly has been
given that you know as we say we are
less than three weeks away from new
trading
circumstances no matter what happens
with these negotiations i'm just
wondering where
you where your assessment is of of where
the blame should fall on the political
leaders on the
the civil servants tasked with
negotiations on the european union
perhaps
after being quite so intransigent a
number of issues
i think we're only going to know that
with hindsight aren't we i mean
until we know where we are and until we
know what we've got it's very difficult
to say
whether any of it was right or wrong but
it won't just be britain it's going to
be the european union both sides have to
come to an agreement so we can all move
forwards
badness mcgregor smith lovely to see you
this morning and a very merry christmas
when it comes
thank you